i love that alex leave me alone alex
leave me alone
i love that um and for those of you that
don't know and you're listening rather
than
watching and my dad sounds different he
is not in the studio right now okay i'm
not in the studio
thank you
thank you you're welcome okay jackie
this was your idea what do you got
planned today it was not my idea this is
the worst possible thing for me i was
called i was called what three hours ago
or something and told you're coming in
we don't have a guest your dad
your dad won't be there
and just show up okay so this is a
podcast and that's what she's done
that's jackie mandel they showed up
there's no guests it's me
i i'll just
and and this could be the title i'm
going [ __ ] insane and even if this
doesn't air and it'll probably air after
this day this is not live
and i'll probably hate everything that
happens on this episode i'm going
[ __ ] insane i'm sorry i'm going
[ __ ] insane i know i'm gonna tell you
um does uh i'm i'm looking uh like i'm
on a zoom that jackie can see jackie you
recognize where i am you're in my old
bedroom
yeah yeah so um i'm just going to say it
i know this might seem unbelievable
ladies and gentlemen
but i [ __ ] got covet
that's how do you you the man in the
bubble how do you get and i remember
when the whole pandemic started people
were making memes like we really need to
be concerned if howie mandel gets
coveted that's when i'll start
and you know what for a guy that that
you know for the last two and a half
years for the last
14 years i i'm really i'm nervous to go
outside i'm nervous to touch people i've
been wearing a mask your mother and i
haven't eaten in a restaurant indoor i
do everything outside everybody who
comes on the podcast had to be tested um
everywhere i work everybody had to be
tested i got [ __ ] callbacks
but you've had a cold and a flu before
and you do all that stuff too when you
protect yourself
so like i it's just a matter of time
here's the thing i got hovid and i'm
doing i was working and and they test
you at work and i got them and i tested
positive i was feeling a little sick i
did get you know i had a little bit of a
cough and they sent me home from work
they sent me home from work i'm going to
be honest with you a [ __ ] week ago
and and uh you know and because i'm
nervous all about about your mother i've
been in this room for a week
i've been in this room this is not i
don't give a [ __ ] about this podcast i
don't i don't know what the content i
just needed to do something
i just needed to talk about it i've been
in one room for a week i have never been
i have never
been
locked in a room in my life for a week
and i know that a lot of you are uh
probably you spend a lot more i just
have mental health issues where for me
in a room with no distractions no work
and no people it's it's real i'm not
complaining i'm complaining i am
complaining and i just wanted to come on
and
even maybe we shouldn't air this
alex
alex my son he's there too look i feel
like i'm just calling for help is is is
this is is this even arable i i think
it's great
wait i can't walk in a [ __ ] room
no not not that part but the part that i
i couldn't tell you're not actually here
no you're i'm not talking about sound
design that's him patting himself on his
back so that people at home will go it
sounds like he's actually in the same
room no that's not what's good about it
what's bad about it is i'm here i'm here
like my friends for the last week jackie
do any of these people look familiar to
you yeah he calls he calls me too on
facetime to show me those stuffed
animals when he said she moved out uh
like 20 some odd years ago in the room
those aren't mine those aren't mine
those are these those are riley's those
are not oh so the other sister moved out
this is the the ugliest scariest stuffed
animals they're up at night all i stare
at is this it's a and you if you're not
if you just watch what is this it's like
a skunk baby mm-hmm
well
but you are still doing agt how are you
doing it
no
no i'm at home
oh i'm at home okay so you're not doing
anything
what about i'm doing nothing and going
[ __ ] insane do you not understand
[Music]
bye